hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode dine video
so much internal screaming this week
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet and new round of
the giveaway starts now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so here we go
let's begin the top seven with Shireen
Baratheon story the dance of the Dragons
she's been so much fun this season and
she's one of the characters she's one of
the few characters that reads a lot
apparently she also reads George RR
Martin's side stories that's what the
dance of the Dragons is she completely
explained it in the episode it's all
about the Targaryen Civil War that tale
provides the emotional core of the
episode you have like the dance that's
going on in Dazz Mack's pit like the
literal dance people dancing around each
other with swords then you have the
internal dance that Stannis was talking
about a man fighting his true nature he
gives you a rare glimpse of what's going
on inside his head do I sacrifice my
daughter and become the man I was
supposed to be he looks like a ghost and
as hard as things have been on them you
know as winter set in it's also because
he's been weighing the decision to
sacrifice Shireen if you haven't read
that short story it's a lot of fun there
aren't any spoilers in it for the main
novels or the TV show or anything like
that it's completely separate there's
also the funny story about Balon Swann
trying to hide behind this really pretty
shield to fool a dragon it totally not
working obviously nice hat tip - what
happened with Drogo at the end of the
episode you could also look at it is an
allegory to what's going on between the
Bolton's and Stannis's army right now
the Bolton's trying to hide behind the
shield of winter maybe what happened
with Drogo at the end of the episode
says something about what's going to
happen with the Stannis Ramsay plot
that's just a theory though you could
spend all day parsing imagery in Game of
Thrones but you know when a character
like Shireen spends a long time
explaining something it's a big deal so
pay careful attention to what she said
in this episode and what it might mean
for the other characters on the show on
to number six
Stannis sends Davos back to the wall to
get more supplies it reminded me of the
story of how sir Davos became The Onion
Knight first of his name it's you know
it's kind of like bran becoming the
first Knight of the Blackwater to
somewhat uh Knightly people helping out
really rich people that raise them up to
knighthood Davos his story is just a
little bit grander than bronze story way
back during Robert's rebellion Stannis
got stuck defending storm's end the
opposing force just chose to starve him
out
so slowly over time Stannis just had
everyone eat all the horses all the
animals they started boiling their shoes
they started boiling leather and eating
that slowly starving to death
Davos came in and brought them a bunch
of onions like he smuggled in food for
them so Stannis would not be alive were
it not for Davos so that's why he made
him the onion night and true to his word
Stannis very fair man cut off all of his
finger joints on one hand Stannis is
very fair but very hard that's why he
told him to kill all the guards that let
Ramsay come in and burn their supplies
he just isn't going to give anybody a
pass nobody gets a free ride with
Stannis on to number 5 though Jon Snow
brings the survivors through to the
other side of the wall as he said he
views the mission as a failure because
they barely got anybody but they did
manage to get out with some of the
wildlings so they do have more people
now there was a real question though as
to whether or not Alliser thorne was
gonna let them through the gate I was
surprised how quickly he did it you got
a good heart Jon Snow it's gonna get us
all killed it's interesting that you see
more hate coming off the faces of the
regular Nights Watch brothers Alliser
Thorne doesn't seem like he harbors that
much of a grudge right now that's okay
though it seems like Olly hates Jon Snow
enough for the two of them you have to
remember that almost like 50 of them
died trying to keep the wildlings from
coming through that gate that they just
walked through that's why it was really
sad when one one came through and
everyone flipped one one is the name of
the giant that survived remember the
other one was killed in the tunnel by
Grenn long live Grand the giant slayer
so everything they were trying to
prevent from happening last season just
happened that's why they hate Jon Snow
so much onto number four
everybody versus his dharm so you have
his door throwing shade at Daario who
throw shade right back at him then you
have Tyrion mincing words with him and I
like Tyrians comment that Tywin would
have totally loved his door killing is
necessary what progress has been made
without killing as nuts as Dario's idea
about pulling a red wedding on the noble
houses of murine seemed a couple weeks
ago it doesn't seem like such a bad idea
now the problem is is if you kill a lot
of people no matter why you do it it's
really hard to call yourself a good
person that's the internal battle that's
going on in Daenerys right now you know
just like Stannis has his own internal
battle trying to decide whether or not
to sacrifice his daughter
what does Daenerys have to do to become
the person she was meant
be probably kill a few people but I mean
it was just fun watching everyone throw
shade at his door so far I see pretty
innocuous but I felt like they were
telegraphing in these moments that they
wanted you to view him is the bad person
his doors all about the old way to
nurses about the news so you know I was
the old in with the new on to number
three Serge Ora enters the fighting pit
it's pretty clear that Daenerys wants to
help him but can't do anything in an
obviously in reference to the dance of
the Dragons title sir Jorah dances with
a lot of these other fighters just
barely makes it out but he is a badass
fighter so he does win the reason I
think that everyone was booing him is
because he was a Westerosi Knight and
they were cheering for the local
fighters a lot of the people hate
Daenerys because they still view her as
an invading force she's from another
culture and she isn't respecting their
so so I think that's why they hated Sir
George so much because he represented
that the announcer made it very clear to
announce to everyone that Jorah was a
Westerosi Knight so no matter what he
did people probably weren't gonna like
him moving on to number two the Duran
Martel let's Jamie go back to King's
Landing worth Myrcella but he has to
take trystane with him this is a small
change in the books
so whenever Tyrion arranged for Marcela
to go to Dorne way way back in season
two before Blackwater part of the deal
was he gave the Martel's a seat on the
small council that's when the books they
didn't really address that on the show
until now Oberyn was originally supposed
to take the seed he died so now there's
an empty seat that belongs to a Martell
in the books it ends up being Obara to
go to King's Landing and sit on the
small Council so it's still a Martell
but a different one there wasn't much of
a climax this week in the in the
dorrance storyline aside from the slap
fight that was going on everybody gets
slapped sand snakes and bran it was nice
of a Laureus ant to tell Jaime you know
I know exactly what's going on with you
and Cersei and it's no big deal if
you've been born a Targaryen or a long
time ago wouldn't have been anything
and finally for my number one you know
just because there was so much internal
screaming this week I split it between
Shireen Baratheon being put to the torch
and Daenerys riding drogon let's start
with our sweetheart Shireen that this
was the saddest moment I think all
season seriously I can't remember
anything else that's made me this upset
who's gonna read stories to serve Davos
now and what's going to happen to stand
us now that it looks like he's killed
the only thing that he loves I'm sure he
cares about
but it seems like Shireen was like the
purest expression of his love even
crazypants Solis was like this is a
terrible idea she's a good barometer for
the audience in this moment you just you
see like the spectrum of emotions that
cross her face from like okay you know
we need to do this all the way to oh my
god no this is happening here's a good
question for you guys were you more
upset about what happened to Sansa with
Ramsay in Episode six or about this
about Shireen being put to the torch
moving up to Daenerys and Rokon though
this had actually been spoiled last year
a little bit and a lot of the behind the
scenes stuff so we knew was going to
happen it's a big moment from the books
drogon comes down in two days next Pitt
Rose a bunch of people then takes off
with Daenerys it was incredibly
cathartic and she you know she even does
like her Jedi mind trick that's not in
the book so that the show is kind of
making a logic leap there she has a
connection with drogon but the books
never fully explained the nature of that
dragon bonding gets tied up in a little
bit of blood magic a little bit of
sorcery it's very complicated
hopefully the books will explain it at
some point I felt like the CG of him
taking off like the skyline and the
pyramid in the background looked way
better than the CG of him landing when
he flew in he's he didn't look quite as
big as I imagined him but I'm really
glad that they did not wait to the
finale to do this and I wouldn't
mentioned either but we also have Ari a
story with Meryn Trant I'm actually I'm
a little happier that they did save that
for the finale because they wouldn't
have done that if it wasn't going to be
just some mind-blowing scene that she
was going to have they want there to be
no question about how evil Meryn Trant
is I actually thought when they trotted
Arion with the oysters he's gonna be
like a perfect age let's do it he almost
made it sound like he was going to
destroy that serving girl that he walked
off with like why would he need another
tomorrow night if he wasn't going to do
something terrible to the one he had
this night and it's pretty clear the
jaqen knows exactly what's going on oh
you know he wasn't hungry maybe tomorrow
and jackets like yeah I know exactly
what you're doing
maybe tomorrow it's all the same to the
many-faced God but I'll be interested to
see what Jack and does if Aria actually
does end killing Meryn Trant that's
actually another good question do you
think that if aria ends up killing Meryn
Trant that Jack and will make her leave
next week's episode is the finale
it's called mother's mercy that could
mean a lot of things mercy as in
Daenerys as the mother of
Bagon shows some mercy in the books Aria
took the name mercy when she was on a
mission like this then we had like the
Sansa Ramsay Bolton storyline you know
what does mothers mercy say about that
if there's anything that I'm really
surprised about at this point it's that
they've drugged out this Cersei
storyline
I would actually thought and they've
gotten to the trial by now I'm wondering
if they're going to send Jaime and
Myrcella and everyone back to King's
Landing before that happens usually the
duration the finales is a little bit
longer so they have a little bit more
room to do extra stuff so now's the time
to make predictions for the finale so
I'll totally do like season six
predictions once we get through but it's
a little early because there's still so
many things that they could change from
the books in the last episode as much as
they've been moving really quickly
through books four and five I feel like
season six will include some stuff that
they cut out from previous books we can
talk about that in a couple weeks
and don't forget tomorrow's the Q & A
I'll announce the winner of the giveaway
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
just in case you guys didn't see it I
did a bonus video today all about acai
and Dragons and how the history of those
two are connected you can click here to
watch that and you can click here for
last week's episode thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow
you